and ain't no put the cat doll edition so
[ __ ]
six holes two words Mortal Kombat it
reminded me you know Jumanji when he
rolled the dice and it was stampede
[Music]
it was Stampede on stage Dyson can we
finish this game too much
Jumanji of drag Jumanji of drag episode
3 did that make your stomach sink at all
being like oh we're this early into the
competition they're having this many
girls do this this could happen to me
right I was like all hell is breaking
loose and it definitely was a wake-up
call cause it's like there was no rules
she'll put everybody in elimination i
was thinking probably next we should
probably up 14 oh how many there was
left I can't do the math I know
mathematician but I knew like I wasn't
making prop for everybody they knew like
okay we cannot play with like you know I
remember them coming back from armed
critiques
we were untucked and they were like girl
we it's gonna be bad
I was a gooda probably be like two three
maybe I was not anticipating six like
I've heard of six ways but not in this
kind of you know scenario you know
usually type it in on the porn sites and
you get something else they battle in
but they battle in like other other way
right and then you end up with a six
soju I'm not saying she had a six way
I'm just saying there's a cream that
will fix it
I'm currently losing standing in the
back of the stage watching all of that
play out in front of you what was going
through your head honey I said we were
just arguing and untouched
we probably feel petty us right now play
the footage please
I want friends to do so
don't go on top and driving la ready if
you leave the desert
nothing mega nice outside the heat is
gonna melt
I don't know so he is a big personality
we are all very passionate people we
take what we do very serious so anytime
fit could be the topic that's gonna
break the star that's gonna break the
camel's back in this case silk is belly
so I mean if Sookie was going off to me
it's a regular Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday and
rinse and repeat I mean we are all
sisters so we're gonna fight and argue
it's like going to the family cookout
and if you and your cousin been fighting
y'all gonna fight and then y'all gonna
say [ __ ] shut up and then you know go
to the grill eat um I was I surprised
no was I surprised it was earlier on yes
I mean you know it is what it is right
Sookie crazy who I mean if you don't get
it at this point episode three that
she's crazy [ __ ] you're not paying
attention to the episode I try to focus
on myself but I will say you know you
have to accept
silky for all of her and Evie and
whoever else the rest of them hold you
know what I'm saying it comes they come
with a lot of ugly some more ugly than
Isis
[Music]